- I have to have a pretty girl.
If she's got no clothes
on, that's even better.
I've worked for Playboy, I've
been doing that for 15 years.
But I was the creator of the
Cheerios bee long, long ago.
I remember it as one of
the earliest things I did.
The bee that I drew, I thought
it would be kind of fun
to do one that looked more like a bee.
So I gave him big
compound eyes and antennas
and that wasn't at all what they wanted.
They thought he was a
little too insect-like,
and insects and cereal,
it's probably not a good combination.
But he eventually ended up
looking like he does now.
We put shoes on him which I
didn't have in the beginning.
Oh, and they gave him a sweater,
so he was wearing something.
- [Interviewer] So he really is more
like a Disney character than an insect?
- Yes.
I, I always say he looks like
Elmer Fudd in a bee suit.
The face became more human.
He got a little nose, of course.
And eyes with pupils, no compound eyes.
- [Interviewer] Why,
what is it with the eyes?
- [Dean] Well the eyes are the main thing.
When you do a cartoon character,
you want to focus on the eyes,
after all and if you can have eye brows
and eyes with pupils,
you need something that can be expressive.
- [Interviewer] Now you work for Playboy?
- [Dean] Yes, yes.
Hef said he liked my
Lady and the Tramp eyes.
I try to keep things a little innocent.